MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Understanding the sentiment
and meaning behind language
requires an architecture
that can handle a lot of data.
Join us as we talk
to Mito.ai about how
they handle their data
processing on this episode
of "Stack Chat."
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about Mito.ai
and what you do?
MARIT RODEVAND: Yeah, so we
help large corporations increase
sales by finding insights
and sales triggers
about their existing customers
and potential prospects,
and we do this by
analyzing large amounts
of unstructured data
on the internet.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
what's the technology
behind how you make your AI?
MARIT RODEVAND: We need
to do a lot of things
with all of this information.
The first thing is detecting--
or separating apple from apple.
People think that's trivial,
but it's actually quite hard.
And we do it in a
language-agnostic manner,
which means that, through
our data-processing pipeline,
we can process any
language, and being
able to do this for all very
difficult cases, not just apple
and apple, but similar ones
in Norwegian and Swedish
and German.
And that's also what makes
our technology unique,
this combination of having a
language-agnostic knowledge
graph, and on top of
that one, building a lot
of machine learning
modules to solve all
these really hard questions.
And we are using Apache Spark
as our main data processing
platform, which Patrick can
talk more in detail about.
PATRICK SKJENNUM: So once the
Spark Streaming application
has pulled all of its
content from Pub/Sub,
it processes it through
our NLP pipeline.
This is where we do
the entity extraction,
we cluster the content,
and we interact
with all of these
machine learning models
that we have trained.
These models, they are
trained in Apache Spark
as well, in a batch
processing unit,
which runs on ephemeral clusters
with preemptive nodes, which
is awesome, because then we
can just spin up 1,000 nodes,
and we can train a
really expensive model
for a short time and not
have to leave them running.
And once we have done
that, the last step
in the stream of
processing pipeline
is to index the data back
into the knowledge graph.
And for that, we're
using Elasticsearch,
which is also a really
awesome piece of software.
It's got really great
searching capabilities, so
you we search for "apples"
and get hits for "apple,"
and that sort of thing.
And once the data is
indexed into Elasticsearch,
it is made searchable from our
APIs, which run in GraphQL.
These APIs run in a microservice
architecture in Kubernetes.
So that is kind of
the ecosystem that
interacts with all
of the data that
is processed in Apache Spark.
MARIT RODEVAND: We make this
API accessible to our customers,
because that's how
they integrate, also,
with our service,
taking data from us
and into their internal CRM
and prospecting systems.
And we've even open-sourced a
programming language in order
to customize APIs in
GraphQL very easily.
So people should check that
out if they want to do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So obviously,
over the last couple of years,
you've learned a ton
about your architecture.
If you could go back
and start again,
what would you take
with you that you felt
was the most important thing?
PATRICK SKJENNUM:
One takeaway here
is that we're using Apache
Spark quite heavily,
and that means that we have
to configure Apache Spark
clusters.
And if I would get a
dollar for every hour
I spend configuring
Spark clusters,
I would be a rich man.
Configuring Spark
clusters is not
something that should
be underestimated.
You need to configure
the topology,
you need to configure how
many nodes you should have,
and all that sort of things.
What you do get
from Spark though
is all of these machine
learning libraries and a lot
of utilities in this ecosystem.
But we could have
utilized those either way,
by using other kinds of systems,
either in Python or likewise.
So one obvious thing that we,
perhaps, should consider more
is utilizing managed
services like Dataflow,
where you can use this
managed service that
can do all of the
transformations,
and then you can use external
APIs to do the machine learning
stuff.
And then you would also
decouple the system
and have the data processing
in one place and the machine
learning contained
in other services.
So when we started off, we
had a single messaging queue
where we published
all of the content.
This meant that if either
that queue went down
or some other service
interacting with a queue
went down, we were
clogging the queue.
We would have a backlog
or a lot of things that
would have to be processed.
And that wasn't sustainable, at
least not when, the customers,
they require that the
delay through our system
is as low as possible.
So as a solution to that,
we swapped over to Pub/Sub
and created this
priority concept
where you, using
machine learning,
can determine which
priority queue
should this content be put on.
And that is based on
feedback from our customers,
either directly
through our API, where
the customers can
choose what is relevant
and what is not relevant.
And based on this, we can infer
what content matters the most
to our customers.
And based on that,
we can utilize
this to route the content
through the right queues, such
that, for instance, a
stock market update is
put on the high-priority
queue because we
know that our customers would
want that as soon as possible.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Thank you
so much for joining us today.
MARIT RODEVAND:
Thanks for having us.
PATRICK SKJENNUM: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Get
started with Dataflow
using these templates
and tutorials.
Thanks for watching, and
make sure to subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
We'll see you next
time on "Stack Chat."
[MUSIC PLAYING]